hey let's get started welcome to this
talk here right now by the Waffen
technology group we'd like to leave
ourselves as your gateway to expertise
with technologies my name is Peter flake
and the manager of the team and we'd
like to kind of give you a few
impressions of what we do in our team
how we do it and how its of a lot of
benefit and value to you okay we have
four sub parts of this presentation so
you get a lot of value for them time
basically the other speakers are sitting
here in front of with me where's Carol I
sensi Michael Kelly and antrim anike
presenting the various sections here and
I will just quickly give you an overview
before handing off to everybody else
again I will be covering the overview so
first of all let me talk about what we
do what kind of in which ways we provide
expertise to you okay our team grew out
of technical support where you've known
beforehand the premier support and what
you've what you complicity got in for a
long time was actually developed to
support you know it's not just
installations we're not just IT stuff
you really get help with programming in
the various moulton products we've added
there recently a couple years ago was
Enterprise Support maybe that's not
quite as known at the same time there's
not the only thing we do there's several
more things as you can see already in
that list we are the continuation of the
Wolfram education group we actually
execute training we create training it
can be done in various many ways it can
be a standard course that you do online
that you in any location around the
world it can be something personal and
custom it can be yeah it can be for
entire team it can be for individual
person next we do sales are nearing
meaning if you're not a customer yet and
you don't I'm sorry and large let's see
we can make the larger
soap it will still fit this is better
okay good technical sales presentations
means if you are not yet a customer but
you would like to find out what our
technologies can do for you then we'd be
glad to come to you and give you a
presentation that speaks of what will be
the benefits what will the possible
solutions to use various technologies
without of ours furthermore taking
little services is if you're not quite
sure how to get something done you don't
have the time for it but you feel like
there's somebody in our team who can do
it for you we'd be glad to do it
technical services is one of the three
different consulting teams we have in
our company compared to a mask or and to
or from solutions we're the ones who are
closer to the code base so if you have
existing code you like to need you have
any changes that you need to be done rid
of it well you'd like to have something
from scratch but in the end you'd like
to understand what's going on this is
our team that you want to talk to
furthermore we take care of all the
feedback that you give us on the various
products we Lobby the R&D team on your
behalf that stuff gets updated gets
improved gets taken care of one of the
examples we had is actually the devices
project that you might have heard about
right now we had gotten feedback from
various from various potential customers
they would love to have data directly in
the product be able to use it and well
Steve likes to solve things that rather
in the big way so he just didn't feel
like maybe just with just one way to
kind of import data he said let's just
do it all so but the the impetus came
from actually talking to us furthermore
we have certain online resources I'd
like to especially mention the support I
fake use the website basically way
hopefully you can find certain answers
to frequently asked questions or certain
topics that come up time and again the
point is that we can update that side as
necessary as we become aware of an issue
that happens to many of you
many of our users we can update that and
let you know as soon as we understand
that something's happening it's not the
same release cycle as the various
products technologies where the stakes /
T's we have impossible to enumerate on
one slide or anything like that I just
like to flash the various products at
you that we help you with that we can
help you with it's everything on the
ball from research side it's not more
from alpha simplifying ly speaking last
but not least a quick before I hand over
to the next speaker I'd like to show a
little bit like what kind of challenges
we have in how we try it adapted how we
tried it up to it first of course the
four of the six areas that I just showed
you these are challenging by itself
there's a lot of technology in all the
various products at the same time we
have very very interesting customers
okay with very interesting problems that
doesn't make it an easier for us ok so
our solutions here and is to have very
highly qualified team members and I just
like to flash a little bit of you of
what diversity of background they have
and the skill level that I have and
otherwise i would talk a long time about
like how i feel that my team members are
very very interesting and not very
helpful people but i don't feel like i
should waste that time right now i'd
rather like you to meet them and talk to
them ok and this can be either through
the various presentations that they've
had already we've done all so that all
the training or a good part of the
training on tuesday including for Millie
who's sitting over there and she will
also give another presentation right
after this presentation here right now
or by sinking cow for example but in any
case unfortunately although many of
these things have passed already but I'd
really encourage you to listen to
whoever's going to follow me right now
or merely right after this presentation
well hopefully everyone can hear me I'm
like Peter said my name is car licensing
and I'll be responsible for the
technical support section this talk and
I do think it's important to discuss
technical support because to put it
bluntly
tickle support at Wolfram research is
this simply different than technical
support at many other companies and a
good hint that it's different than
technical support at many other
companies is just in who's doing it here
at Wolfen research you know we aren't
hiring people you know from the local
high school we aren't hiring people even
from across the street at the University
of Illinois you know people doing
technical support here at Wolfram
research oftentimes a PhD PhDs I have a
PhD in astrophysics I'd say roughly
maybe half the department has phd's but
near the rest of the department has
master's degrees so we're talking about
people generally have advanced degrees
in some area of science engineering
mathematics these people have technical
backgrounds in science usually with some
kind of programming background so that's
one good hint that what we're doing is
quite a bit different than what people
generally associate with technical
support all right so what exactly do we
do well we really are essentially a
central department here at Wolfram
research and that's what's kind of one
theme I want to bring up as I'm going
through this section over and over again
in that yes we're communicating with the
public and that's very important but as
you communicate with us what you should
be realizing is that we communicate with
many different departments here at
Wolfram research so we're certainly
communicating with QA you know the
feedback you give us a certainly
communicating the keyway we're also
communicating with developers directly
and communication can go multiple ways
in that you know we might get
information from our developer and pass
it on to you but you know we might also
be passed information from you the user
on to our developer so if you find a
problem in Mathematica or you have a
suggestion for existing functionality we
can pass that information on to a
developer so that communication you know
both ways and we also can communicate
with management so for example
especially when we release in new
products which is something we're doing
a lot recently for example the Wolfram
cloud we communicate with our met with
our management all the time directly in
technical support so I know that when we
released the Wolfram cloud pretty much
every week we would have a meeting where
the management would ask okay what are
the users saying about the Wolfram cloud
are they encountering any problems
what suggestions for improvements are
they making on a weekly basis weekly
basis you know what do they have to say
and we give that feedback directly to
management and they can disseminate that
information to developers working
underneath them so we really are kind of
a central unit here at Wolfram research
and therefore communicating with us you
know as the public is very important
once we really do act as the central
conduit okay so this is you know much of
this is repetition from what Peter said
but we really do support a huge range of
products there they're almost as many
products as there are people in
technical support we're responsible for
a lot of different types of questions
this can range all the way from
installation questions which can
essentially be you know put the DVD in
the drive and make it go all the way up
to complicated programming questions so
we cover a huge range of questions which
means that we're essentially talking to
a huge range of people this can go all
the way from you know professors
including people who have won you know
prestigious awards you know people very
prestigious people and famous people in
industry all the way down to students
and their parents who are frankly you
know not as competent of some of these
other people and so we have to be able
to communicate with a huge swath of
people with different abilities and
these people come from a wide variety of
different domains you know they might
have an IT background they might have a
mathematics background that may have an
engineering background they may have
just a general kind of programming an
industry background and we communicate
with these people different channels so
the main point here is that there's you
know for an engineer like myself there's
really no way that we can communicate
with all these different people you know
about all these different products and
be an expert in every one of these areas
but because we are an expert on wolfram
products in general we can oftentimes we
can pretty much always say something
useful to all of our users about
whatever questions they have and give
them some information to begin with and
then even if we can't answer the
question completely to begin with even
though we're giving them some in useful
information we can at least communicate
with our developers get back to them and
then within a short amount of time get
them additional useful information so we
get them started on the problem a lot of
times even if we don't have their exact
domain-specific knowledge and then we
talked to a
upper and get some additional
information in a later point in time to
get their problem completely solved and
so that's kind of the general workflow
that we seek to do in the technical
support department so we've been
speaking in terms of kind of abstract
and you know a little bit of hand waving
here so let's look at some kind of a
specific case you know a couple specific
cases that we've encountered in the past
and so these are these are pretty simple
cases because the point isn't really to
demonstrate how clever we are or
anything like that the point is to show
just our general workflows so you know
we shouldn't get caught up in the
details these cases because frankly
they're not very complicated we should
be just examining the workflows of how
we work in technical support so this was
an issue that came in in the mathematic
and nine days and this is about control
system engineering specifically the root
locus plot function now to speak to what
I was talking about in the previous
slide you know my background is in
astronomy so frankly I don't know a lot
about root locus plots I'm not a control
system engineer and this really came
down to how to you know what were the
details of interpreting the root locus
plot I might be in a little bit of
trouble here but I do know a whole lot
of a visualization in Mathematica and I
am you know an expert in that so what a
user did is they came in with this
question of it they said okay this is
what new Mathematica does and this is
what Mathematica comes up with in
Mathematica nine if you just basically
give it a generic this generic locus
plot and they said they said okay this
doesn't look quite right with just
essentially default options you know
this should be more circular down here
essentially and not quite as filled in
along the axis and so the question is
they ask me okay how can you make this
look a little bit better and so I can
give them a little bit of information
right away I could point out okay you
know basic plotting in Mathematica you
might have to tweak some options like
you might have a plot points option you
might infer these these plotting
functions that have a solver behind the
scenes you might have to get a little
bit better efficiency by using a
different method so I pointed out okay
you can drastically improve your plot by
increasing the plot points and using a
different numerical solving method using
the generic solve method and this
allowed the user to get exactly what
they wanted now on the other hand this
is hardly ID
because they had to use something like
4,000 plot points and that's not great
because if you were to actually run this
it would take you know over 10 seconds
to generate which is not something you
know that's not a great situation
ideally you would be able to generate a
plot like this much more quickly so the
user got what they wanted but it's still
not ideal and it's still not done deal
state for the software so speaking to
you know how technical support is kind
of essential department here at Wolfram
research you know in addition just
giving the user that work around I was
also able to communicate to our
developers hey you know this even though
it works technically in mathematica 9
it's something we need to work on and so
I talked to our QA department I talked
to the developer on this functionality
and we were able to get it very quickly
improved in future versions the
mathematica specifically you know
basically within just a couple days the
developer was able to look at it you
know realize the problems and fix it so
that now in mathematica 10 instead of
taking you know even with those
additional options it would taking a 15
seconds so to evaluate in mathematica 10
evaluating your one second or so with
much with far fewer plot points so the
basic point is you know we were we are
able to not only get you a workaround we
were able to get a fix in future
versions of Mathematica and once this
user kind of discovered this
functionality or this feature of a
technical support we're able to get
things like this improved they were able
to find feature other things in root
locus plot that could also be improved
and they actually had three suggestions
through to our QA and our developers
resulted in three improvements to root
locus plot for mathematic at ten now
this is a pretty simple example of just
you know something that we can give
people in our visualization
functionality we can of course do kind
of more in-depth developer support as
well which is something else that Peter
was speaking to so one thing that
someone came through to me with is they
said okay I have this giant piece of
code and you know this is it right here
well it's not that giant but it's at
least you know a somewhat substantial
piece of code right here whether do it
just trying to do a little bit of math
and mathematica and you know they're
doing a bunch of numerical integrals and
whatnot in math this is once again
mathematic and nine and they got some
error messages but you know the warning
message
didn't stop their code from evaluating
and so they weren't too concerned with
that you know maybe they should have
been but the main problem they were
encountering was okay well these
numerical integrals are just taking too
long to evaluate if you look at the
timing here is taking something like
1500 seconds to val way and that just
seemed unreasonable to the user and so
in this case they asked me okay well how
could you know you know how could we
improve this certainly you know tech
support person there's some way to speed
up this this code right here the
normally this is probably a little bit
larger piece of code than we would like
to look at in technical support but you
know despite Lansing at it we're able to
tell us user okay there are in fact a
few ways we can improve your piece of
code here you know one quick way is
maybe instead of using if statements you
would rewrite your functions as
piecewise functions that's not the
biggest improvement you can make here in
fact you could just recognize from the
error messages that you're in fact
encountering a common problem and you
know the point of this talk doesn't
recognize this kind of problem with the
point of it but you know if you ever
seen these error messages before the
problem that they're encountering is is
that a symbolic value is being passed to
and integrate and so if you if you use
the ? numeric q argument to these
functions you can get rid of these error
messages and so with about 10 minutes of
playing around with this I realize that
you could actually get rid of these
error messages and if you got rid of the
error messages um you would speed up the
code by you know approx effect or 40 or
so and so you know I was able to give
that user that worked around and of
course that current user was very happy
with this okay my code you know has very
quickly been sped up x factor for years
so that so that individual user was
happy but then I was able also able to
recognize okay you know this is a common
problem users encounter this error
message all the time and helping users
on a case-by-case basis that's not so
great for us and technical support and
it also probably means that there's a
lot of other users out there who are
encountering this not even telling us
about it they just kind of live with
slow code and you know maybe even users
out there who don't have from your
service and would still like to help
them so what can we do for all those
other users and the answer is we can
actually write support faq s to inform
future users in Mathematica about how
problems like this can be fixed
so we've written a series of articles
based on feedback we've gotten from
existing users will support wolfram calm
/ kb and based on feedback I've gotten
from users and so in this case it's
basically covers how you could fix error
messages like this and so you can see
this is basically an article inspired by
this and this would this would help out
future users we have articles for this
another common one for example would be
oh you know I have a large Excel
spreadsheet I can't bring it into
mathematica how could I fix that well
we'd have an article for that we would
say hey you can just increase your Java
heap space now and fix that problem
because that's another very common when
we see and we have a lot of articles of
that type based on our experience with
other users so we try and help both our
current users and their future users at
the same time by writing these articles
so yes my name is Michael Kelly and I
specialize in finance I'm one of these
people who has a PhD and was a professor
you may be asking yourself why would I
be doing this when I could have the
great glory of teaching people boring
things at university because it's a lot
more fun actually a lot more fun much
more intellectually challenging wide
range of problems and I can actually
apply things I've learned and the people
are really interested to find the
answers not pass exams so these type of
it makes for a much better working
environment and experience and as the
others have said there's such a wide
range of people working there they're
exciting and interesting to talk to and
it's one of the best companies from an
intellectual point of view so those are
the main reasons and as they're also
saying we have a wide range of products
and it's not possible to know absolutely
everything in detail but i find this a
great challenge it means that i'm
constantly learning so it's there's a
good fun aspect but I concentrate mainly
on the finance platform but that's not
the only thing I mean I know a lot about
Mathematica have been using it for a
long time and I'm capable of speaking to
people from different programming
backgrounds because my great age I tried
just about every other program before i
came across Mathematica and realized I
didn't you know this
was my true love so that's why I'm sort
of here and doing this type of area and
so as you've seen in our front end it's
there's so much there and you know so if
we just went to the the documentation
let me just bring it up here there's and
let me make it a lot bigger there's so
much here I mean every time you click on
anything you know and then you go into
anything like this this is one of our
new areas structured data sets and the
rest it just keeps growing I find this
very interesting and the the idea is
that it has a cutting edge in just about
everything so I find that it's one of
the few areas where for instance in my
own specialty in finance it's necessary
to know a lot about partial differential
equations because you know say you the
heart of the subject would be the
black-scholes equation and that is
really the solution of the heat equation
with special boundary conditions and
that defines all the possible options
you need to know but some boundary
conditions are so impossible and
introduced discontinuities that you then
have to turn to stochastic differential
equations if any of you work in this
area you know that there are basically
finance people who just work in partial
differential equations and there are
people who just work in stochastic
differential equations and they never
talk to one another because it takes up
so much time you know if you really want
to practice in that area in as an
academic you never have time in your
life to do really become an expert in
the other well working in this
environment forces me to know something
about the other and how they
intercommunicate so you know that's one
of the benefits I think of this there's
this type of job and we have both of
those things so if you go into
mathematica we have D solve and ND solve
for partial differential equations and
we have the ito process function which
allows you which essentially applies
Ito's lemma to stochastic differential
equations so these are very important
very powerful tools
the other thing I do of course besides
solve these type of problems that
everyone's talking about and do
consulting is that we have a very wide
range of demonstrations and if you go
into our demonstration site you'll find
that there are I think there's more than
7,000 or something demonstrations 9000 s
and there are hundreds and hundreds on
Finance and so basically any any of
those that have to be updated or any new
ones that come my way I mean I'm
responsible for sort of checking through
them making sure they work making sure
it makes sense and i'm also the default
person for finance for economics so you
know they're mildly related i guess so i
also write about those type of things
and offer advice to you know people who
do economic analysis and econometrics
analysis which means that i didn't have
to know something about statistics and
also you know you find that because i
was started off as a professor of
mathematics oh i'm always end up being
the guy that's got to answer some
problem about group theory or something
like that as well so in a particular way
I never lose contact with a lot of the
things I've learned in the past rather
than just specializing in one thing so
you might have seen this before this is
one of the examples in our website you
know where we're looking at looking at
the surface of volatility surface in the
heston model so this is where you have
stochastic volatility building to your
option pricing regime so and I really
like I think this is our demonstrations
website offers a fantastic way to learn
basic concepts and a whole range of
topics and also to present your material
and a large part of my work actually is
showing things like this to people and
then convincing them that this is an
interesting way either to offer course
or to explain their material to their
manager or to explain it to their fellow
colleagues and so on and it's been one
of our best I think products in terms of
showing the power of math
so when I do go to a client or anything
like this we you know we show these type
of manipulate functions all of these are
manipulate functions you know so you
could looking at loading down some data
starting different sets of data in
different ways and getting different
results looking at model fitting and
doing various tests on all of these
things so this is the type of material
at you know you would be showing people
to explain how our statistics functions
work and the notion here of course is
that we have so many functions built in
I think now we have more than 5,000 so
it's literally a complete and total
language unto itself and these type of
models get across many ideas
simultaneously and show the breadth of
the notions that are involved so I think
that this type you know so for instance
this one here just shows the range of
here we've got univariate discrete
probability distributions but if I
wanted to look at all both discrete and
continuous univariate and multivariate
you can see that there's a you know
extraordinarily large number here and we
can choose interesting ones like the
fresh a distribution and then go down
here and look at it CDF and change the
parameters in a dynamic fashion so and
it also makes it possible for instance
when you are doing consulting and so
there is a fair amount of consulting
where I do for people using a connect
session so I can be sitting at home they
can be sitting thousands of miles away
and we could they be explaining some
problem that they've got they'll give me
the data and I can sort of quickly sort
of get a quick mock-up model going using
something like this and it doesn't take
me very long and at least that the idea
is not to get a complete solution but at
least the outline to the client what is
possible and get them some ideas as well
and I think this is a very this is an
extremely powerful method for explaining
ideas to clients and more or less having
them realize that
you know we're capable of solving almost
any type of problem so you know just to
give you and also the other thing I
should point out is the power of wolfram
alpha 2 so we often go to clients and
they say you know well you know we don't
use Mathematica here and how powerful is
it and I think just showing them the
power of Wolfram Alpha so this is a
program built using Mathematica and the
Wolfram language and then just basically
folding in a lot of data using our
pattern matching methodology and the
full range of our computational
capabilities to solve incredible
problems and it the basic whether or not
they're going to use wolfram alpha the
point is it it really convinces people
that you can do anything with this
program that its reach is unlimited so
so I'm forever using it and showing
people we can quickly download the data
to do this type of analysis so just got
a tiny bit of code here but as you can
see it was a tiny piece of code just
going off to some site so you know one
of our clients for instance said he
wanted to be able to look at the bid-ask
spreads in the foreign exchange market
for the purpose of analyzing them and
then building indicators that would be
appropriate to this market we already
have over I think about a hundred
financial indicators but I then went on
to build up something for him and as you
see here so this is actually getting the
data now I can nothing much seems to be
happening here I could update it
so we're looking at every half second
still nothing much is happening there
but there and you know so while that's
happening I could go down to the next
one here and look at the exchange rate
for the British Pound to the US dollars
and see what it's doing again not much
but the whole idea is that you get a
notion of the of the spread of the
values that are happening there and you
can then quickly generalize all of this
so that i can say well okay i'm not just
interested in one of those i can change
also the rate at which it's updating and
say so being in australian how is the
Australian dollar changing relative to
the US dollar and things like that you
know so I'm forever moving money
backwards and forwards so studying the
sort of bid-ask spread looking for those
but and you can it's very simple then to
write a program when the you know when
the bid goes up and the ass remains the
same well the ass goes down and the bid
remains the same that you will
respectively buy and sell and then you
can make each one of these you know if
you buy a thousand or several thousands
of this you're just collecting pennies
but it's easy to do and it's an easy way
to make money just quickly accessing
this type of information so let's see if
we've got something that's interesting
see it updates immediately no it's a
very flat market today I guess it's the
end of the week yes friday everyone's
gone home so there's problems like that
other types of stuff that I get involved
in so I have one group we have an
enormous data set and so using our new
capabilities with data set I can then go
into that and analyze it so this is an
enormous you know data set of you know
about a terabyte or something like that
so I then siphoned off certain portions
of it Wendy and just said apply the
histogram to look at say one of the
arguments here the final odds and with
this of course I can work out the
distribution of winning certain in this
case it was for racing for winning
certain races I could then go in and
make queries about you know various
factors involved in winning races so
what was the average class rating and
final odds average spread the jockey
performance the various measures of
pacing for the horses and things like
this that this I could then use things
like estimated distribution to work out
what's a probability distribution of
winning horses on various tracks around
the country and things like that so this
is the the type of thing you know a
completely unexpected thing that you end
up doing and then eventually I can find
what are the characteristics of winners
and you find more or less like and the
standard deviation of their performance
so you can get a characterization of
what would be you know a top winning
horse so what I'll do is just pass this
on now to an chu and if you've got any
other questions or queries please leave
them to the end and I'll try to answer
them name thanks very much my name isn't
romanik and I manage the technical
service services operation so basically
what i want to present today would be
the bigger picture so far you know there
have been so many talks about so many
different
new functionalities that have come up
and you know how people in very very
broad range of areas can do so much with
them my team does the work of actually
aggregating the things together now this
is of course a conceptual picture of you
know what your work may involve or what
your team may be doing or an entire
company may be doing as a big team so
you know somebody comes up with an idea
you do some amount of research some
amount of exploration then you go
through design and planning
implementation testing you may have to
go through a loop you reiterate get a
better solution and then finally you go
to deployment however some very
practical problems that we face is that
these different stages are being covered
by different people may be completely
different groups and as Michael was also
alluding to earlier that in many
instances these groups do not have a
mechanism or culture and resources to
actually work together and therefore
what ends up happening is that these
different stages they get worked on in
very very different ways and then you
have various pieces that are put
together somehow glue together and get
the thing to work in fact I visited many
companies you know some of the biggest
ones Chrysler for CDC Kodak and so on
and I was surprised that Justin Ford
alone for example there are about 200
labs and the fact is that they are using
more than hundred different systems to
do their work now that is one kind of
problem the other problem is that even
if you want to get rid of this this
scenario what do you actually do there
are two things that are required number
one we need a technology which can span
these different areas and we need people
who can actually visualize these
front pieces at the same time and then
come up with a system that is going to
be very efficient and that is going to
have a stream line flow now practically
what happens is that even when you have
the tools to get this bigger picture is
not always travel in many cases all that
you actually need is some amount of help
and that's where technical services team
comes into picture so our goal is to be
able to fill that gap and over time we
have come up with the understanding that
these three major offerings basically
cover that those gaps number one is
advanced training you can read it from
Beth is it too small okay good so in
advanced training we go one step beyond
the standard training so you may know
that there are online courses available
at travel from training website but then
when you are working on a specific
project you have a specific you know a
group of things that you want to work on
and the general courses may not give you
enough depth to be able to work with
them at that point we can actually help
when you come to us you say we're
working on sentences project we do not
know where to start or we do not know
how the pieces fit together we can sit
with you we can train you in those
relevant functionality help you actually
go through that project from our side
it's customized to your needs it goes
with the pace that you want and take
only as much help as you need from us
you are not required to buy a package as
such so you can buy just fires for 10
hours or you know 30 hours their
companies who buy several days worth of
training for the employees and so on the
second offering is development support
where we work with you and to the extent
that you need help to that extent we
will go so let's say that you are doing
design work we would provide
recommendations what will be good design
let's say that you are actually doing
coding we can do some amount of coding
for you but you will have full control
over
what what actually goes into the
solution or the project that you are
doing we provide recommendations and
then you choose and the solution that
comes out is of course yours the last
stage the last offering is project
support let's say that you don't have
the time or you know the personnel to be
able to complete a certain project we
can take the specs from you we take the
data we do it entire implementation and
then we deliver now I'm going to show
some examples and these are basically to
spark your imagination project ideas so
almost any kind of data analysis work
that you may be doing of course Wolfram
language has very powerful functionality
to do them and in those instances where
you may not be very aware as to what
kinds of things can be done with that
data come talk to us and we can give
ideas because we have a team that works
together they're experts in different
fields but then because we are working
together we can actually do very amazing
things and and that has been the history
so far you're doing any kind of
statistical modeling simulation image
processing almost any kind of automation
that you want to do you know you can
come and talk to us so here are some
examples and this is interesting
actually an orthopedic surgeon somehow
he came to know about math America and
he was working on this this problem
which is a research problem by at the
same time tis being practiced that this
is the human humerus bone so it's from
the right right and I think and the
angle that this axis makes with the top
axis that basically tells them a whole
lot whole lot about the health of this
bone there may have been accident there
may have been some amount of damage and
the way they measure it that that angle
is called retroversion angle and that's
obviously measured through x rays what
he wanted to do was he wanted to get a
feel for exactly how these x-rays give
out these angles
is it that it is a angle an angle that
they will get no matter who has it or is
it that in different accidents even if
the damage was saying the anger will
come out to be same how do you do this
kind of testing you can't have people
get into an accident come to my lab and
let's see if the angle is same or not of
course not and that's why he approached
us now of course none of us are doctors
here in fact at some point I had decided
I will be but when I went to my college
and I took my first biology class within
two weeks I was pretty clear that's not
the field I can follow so but then
here's a doctor talking to me and you
know he's talking his language I am
talking my language what did what we did
was we SAT together I got all the
details from him and we came up with
this tool within just 15-20 hours of
work and this has done wonders for him
because number one he can actually go
through different views of this humerus
bone and see how the alignments actually
fit together not only that in his field
there is lot of research going on excuse
me with what should be the criteria for
choosing these axes because there is no
Universal definition right so we
implemented this option box for him
where he can go ahead and choose the
axes and actually he can make a
combination of the different protocols
that are being used currently and then
he basically now let's let's look at
this angle so if he goes ahead and
basically uses another protocol you see
that the retroversion angle is going to
change this tool gave them a lot of
insight as to the diagnosis process that
they are following today that's actually
robust or not an answer was it's not but
then for the for the patients is very
very good news now initially nobody
would have thought that competition can
be used in diagnosing a disease related
to
human humerus bone but because he
started talking to us here is a solution
that now he has presented in two
different conferences and it has been
received very very well here is another
example it's a very simple example and
it is on purpose that I am showing the
small examples first company approached
me they basically have big big jobs that
get assigned to lot of machines and they
need to do scheduling but scheduling is
not you know as simple as start and
finish there are probabilities
associated with that and there are
dependencies associated with that one
bar basically represents one job on one
machine and these different colors they
represent different stages and
probabilities the problem is if they
want to see where they are how would
they do that is there a tools that can
just plug into their environment and
give them this kind of visualization
actually no we we actually developed
this interface for them within hardly 10
or 12 hours and now they can go back and
basically check at any point let me see
so they can check at any point what's
happening with you know jobs related to
a particular group or jobs related to
let's say a particular machine and
almost all kind of scenarios that they
may want to now this is actually a
custom tool for them they could not have
purchase it off the shelf but now just
because they have this tool in hand
their life has become much easier in
fact you will be surprised and it may
seem obvious you know at the outset and
you know when we are looking at things
from distance if you look at this pie
chart when they saw this pie chart they
were super excited because they had
spent enormous amount of time making
sure that the jobs has scheduled in such
a way that there is proper distribution
of those jobs across the machines but
they never had a very
picture as to how successful they have
been in doing that scheduling work this
gives them a very clear picture but
actually what they did was pretty good
but they couldn't have actually known
even if there was a problem and 10
unless the problem was you know very big
that they need to improve now having
this tool they can do that very easily
it took us less amount of time and now
they are actually going to implement
this in their production system let's go
to well this you have seen cell skip
here is another one now many of you may
have attended talks on time series
modelling time series forecasting let's
say that you know you're working for a
certain company they're working with
sales data or you know any kind of data
that basically streams with time if you
do not have time series background it's
actually intimidating even to try a
modeling even if it happens to be an
automatic you know automated model
choose are still you will be hesitant
and that's what you know this company
was facing basically so they wanted a
custom tool for their data set which is
just going to give them forecasts and
that the employee they don't have to
worry about knowing time series so this
is something that we created for them
within like eight or nine hours of work
oh maybe I have no I didn't put the data
set here and that's why it's not getting
the time period so what it does we can
see from here is the user just needs to
browse through to a data set data
location imports it then he chooses the
product of course it's a very large data
set he chooses a product line and then
Wolfram language basically chooses the
correct method gives him the forecast
for next you know a few days he can
select the period you know according to
the
needs now this interface is an
application in itself the end user does
not need to know anything about
programming if he can point and click he
can use this tool now consider your
situation as an engineer let's say you
know you're doing this kind of work what
happens is if you're doing time series
modelling every single time that work
comes to you right and then after
sometime it's too monotonous it's too
boring you want to do something new you
want to grow in terms of intellectual
abilities you want more challenges you
create this tool give it to them they
can continue using as as you can start
doing you know things which are more
complex which are more challenging for
you in fact this is interesting this
came to me from Christian priests from
faith and grace org basically when
sermons are going on they videotape them
but then they want people to be able to
see the verses that the preacher is
talking about and he wanted that there
should be a very very easily usable tool
that he can handle while he is doing the
videotaping work itself and we came up
with this tool for him which basically
has entire Bible hidden behind it it's a
CDF file of course right now I'm running
it in notebook environment what we
delivered is a CDF file he can go ahead
and pick and choose the particular book
that the priest may be talking from the
chapter the verse number and so on how
much time did he hear almost over okay
okay this is the second last example I
think and then he can go ahead and
display that and this is a floating
screen that he can put on his recording
device his control panel can be on on
one screen this can be another screen
and he is videotaping at the same time
now who had him
imagine that a Christian priest would be
using Wolfram language it the only thing
that the only gap was that he had to
come and talk to us that happened and he
has this tool in fact he is attending
the conference here I took permission
from him to demo this now they are very
happy because they have a custom tool in
their hand which otherwise obviously is
not available in the market now the
examples that I showed so far they're
smaller examples but in those instances
where your work may actually involve
several stages in processing then what
do you do you can develop entire
applications oops sorry you can develop
entire applications in Wolfram language
and as you can see in this case there
are several steps involved here so
whatever the product line is let's say
that's 0.1 let's say those thousand he
can then there may be you know different
options that the person has he can do
clear all or choose all or he can select
or deselect any particular ones that he
wants or doesn't want save choices
similarly he'll be able to choose
options here and so on let's save there
may be other parameters involved then
there may be a next stage where he is
choosing scenarios there's actually risk
analysis that is being performed here in
the background he chooses these
scenarios then he needs to put in more
amount of data which are relative to the
specific stages in the process so he
needs to specify how many stages so
let's say if I said five then he can go
ahead and have put in these entries or
he can actually load these from a file
or he may add special units to this now
I'm not going through filling all of
that because they'll take time but he
can add special units which actually
requires a different kind of
crossing on together that allows him to
specify how many special units are there
let us say so in this way now you can
see there are so many different stages
that are involved in this case but then
all this has been built using Wolfram
language advantage there are generic
software's for genetic work that we do
but they're very few specific software's
which can do this kind of work which
actually spans many different areas
that's that's the platform that we
intend to offer that's the platform that
we are offering and to put this kind of
work together to create such tools and
then be able to do great things with
those that's what we try to do with our
customers so if you have pretty much any
kind of project in mind you do not know
where to start you do not know what
different pieces are or how they can
work together come talk to us and we can
work together so let me go ahead and
close this the last slide
the expertise that's available in this
team basically covers all these areas
but what I am most proud of is that we
always try to understand understand
customers needs and we have been I can
say proudly that we have been able to
take care of their situations in in
almost all the cases but in majority of
the cases we have been able to come up
with ideas and solutions which were
beyond their imagination now because
there is a team I would call it a very
rich team who is working for them and
therefore that's my appeal to you that
you come to us we'll help you do great
things